You endorsed two saunas, which one would you recommend?
Here's another one for that was recommended on
Amazons and this is much less expensive so this sauna is I looked it up on Amazon
It's like 560 bucks or something like that. I don't know. I can't vouch for that sauna. I have
One of the two that that we sell on our site
I
Really like it. What I've heard from other people having these less expensive saunas is that they take longer to heat up
Now if that's not an issue for you if you can zip up your sauna and
And sit there longer or you can turn it on and unzip it and climb in while you're gonna lose most of heat the time
You zip it up. You're gonna so you're just gonna it's gonna take longer most likely. Now I
I
Personally do not buy all the hype about
Whether it's an infrared far infrared sauna
Dear infrared sauna or it's using far and dear infrared
And the reason why I don't buy that hype with any of the saunas that are on the market any of the saunas that are on the market is
Because none of them are true
far infrared so we have that
Infrared heating device that's called hyperthermia and we have that for sale in our store and
There's probably a dozen of our patients that haven't maybe some of you that are on this call have to have our far infrared
Hyperthermia machine now there's a reason why it's $5,000 and it's the plate is only about
6 by 10 inches around that
Because that's how much it comes to make a true far infrared
device
These saunas that are sold for a thousand dollars
Even these wooden ones you're just paying for the wood that are sold for $5,000 and they say they have an
Infrared heat device and that they show a picture and it's it's red
You're the amount of in true infrared that's coming off of there is minuscule so they're using the studies that are out there on
Something like our hyperthermia machine and it equating that to well because they have 1% true infrared coming on as their sauna
Apparitis is that it's a true infrared sauna. Well, it's just not there's just not
Legal standards to this. So really I've said you know for ever
That the real purpose of the sauna is to get you to sweat
So if the $560 sauna can get you to sweat. It's accomplishing its purpose. So
By all means I would go for the less expensive one the only thing that you had to be careful of is that you just have to know that
It might take 20 minutes to heat up and you just have to be okay with that. So
That's all I've heard from other people that have used less expensive sonas and you have to be able to sweat if your son is not getting you to sweat
It's not accomplishing its purpose
Oh idea of the sauna is to get you to sweat so that you're detoxing through your pores and taking some pressure off of your liver detox pathways
That's the whole idea of the sauna
Now these sauna companies will give you all this hype about our red deer and red mixed and red all this stuff
It's a bunch of baloney because there's really truly not enough in red in any of these sodas to give you any health benefits that they're clavied off the infrared piece
So just know that